- You typically bring people together,
but you and your wife, Abby,
set off a fierce online
debate regarding dishwashers.
- Yes, she is so controlling
about the dishwasher, Kelly.
Sometimes, I load it
and she will reload it
when I leave the room.
So it's more organized.
I don't know what people's
problem is about doing that.
I'm not sure.
- Well, just to let you know,
I have found her
doppelganger and that is me.
I am Abby. (laughs)
I am the one.
I'm like, just stop. (laughs)
Like, I'll do it.
But we have the video
that kicked this off.
It's awesome.
- [Abby] This is a kerfuffle.
- [Glennon] What are you talking about?
- [Abby] Glennon, this is not
how you pack a dishwasher.
- [Glennon] It's gonna
wash the same exact dish.
- [Abby] No, no, no, no, no.
Here's the problem.
When I redo this, it
wouldn't even need to wash.
We could wait a whole day.
- You know what?
You, oh, you're gonna redo this.
You are unbelievably dish controlling.
(Kelly laughs)
- I don't know, Glennon.
(audience claps)
I saw that and I was like,
- Kelly,
it's an untamed dishwasher.
That is an untamed dishwasher.
- I-
Well, something should be
tamed is what I'm saying
because I saw that and
I was like, oh my God.
And if there's food on it, I can't.
Like, I don't think you
need to, like, wash it.
But like, there's not tiny
people in the dishwasher,
like, scrubbing it for you, you know?
So you gotta do a lot.
I am 100% Abby on this one,
so you have lost me in this.
But I want to say,
it's nice, though,
to have a partner, like, in life
that will do the dishes with you.
I'll say that.